ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen zu Hause
geht ob sie es heute mitbekommen haben
aber es gab eine Stellenausschreibung
und zwar von der HU Berlin was wurde
gesucht ein Mensch für das Amt
Antidiskriminierung und es sollte kein
weißer sein wir sehen uns hier gerade
eingeblendet wir bitten daher weiße
Menschen von einer Bewerbung für diese
Beratungsstelle abzusehen ich muss Ihnen
sagen es hat mich schockiert was wäre
passiert wenn für eine Bewerbung ein
schwarzer ausgeschlossen worden wäre was
wäre passiert wenn eine Frau
ausgeschlossen worden wäre die
Feministin in Deutschland werden
hochgegangen und das zurecht wie kann es
also sein auch wenn es eine Uni ist das
muss man natürlich betonen das sind
Studenten aber die kann es sein dass ein
weißer ausgeschlossen wird ist ein
riesiger für mich ist es Rassismus pur
ich bin gespannt wie ist meine Runde
sieht
da mache ich den Anfang ich würde an
dieser Stelle einmal ganz kurz und laut
Vorsicht sagen weil ich glaube wir
müssen unterscheiden zum einen wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe ist es nicht
die Humboldt-Universität die direkt
diese Stelle ausgeschieden hat also es
ist nicht öffentliche Verwaltung Start
es ist eben die Studentenschaft und die
sind ja wie wir alle wissen
grundsätzlich tendenziell linker
positioniert jetzt auch
Studierendenschaft würde mich wundern
das ist ja der nicht die nächste Stufe
dieses Irrsinn in ihrem Alter besser
informiert als ich ich ändere nicht muss
ich dazu weißer alter Mann wundert mich
sowas gar nicht ja ich bin das nur
gewöhnt Alter weißer Mann finde ich
übrigens eh eine Frechheit und ich sagen
lieber alter weiser Mann das gefällt uns
bald besser das wird bei mir immer mit
der SZ geschrieben muss ich sagen aber
ist überrascht mich dass wir überrascht
sind ich meine das ist eine ganz normale
Entwicklung die letzten Jahren was der
rassismusdebatten in Deutschland geht
ich meine genau solche Ideologien werden
von Kanzleramt finanziert mit einem
Milliarden Euro um Rass zu bekämpfen
aber ihre Vorstellung von Rassismus ist
so einseitig ist so rassistisch
teilweise dass man eigentlich nur vom
Minderheiten spricht und von Mehrheiten
die die Macht haben die Polizei als
Instanz wird nicht nur in Frage gestellt
sondern als ein eine Art von
gewaltvoller Sammeln von Männern gesehen
Alter weißer Mann
Postkolonialismus im großen Sinne das
sind alle ideologischen Vorstellungen
die ihre Ursprung leider an der
Universitäten haben und leider
mittlerweile unsere Medien unsere
Debatten bestimmt aber es gab einen
Grund die haben das auch begründet warum
ein warum weiße ausgeschlossen wurden
von der von der
Bewerbung und zwar war nämlich die
Begründung dass ein weißer ist nicht
nachfühlen kann also das ist für eine
weiße Person und weißen Menschen
also rein psychologisch und aus der
emotionalen Ebene heraus argumentiert
würde ich auch sagen nehmen wir doch
ganz anderes Beispiel mit wem erzählt
man als Tochter sage ich jetzt mal oder
seine erste Liebe seinen ersten
Liebeskummer und seine Emotionen
eigentlich tendenziell der Motor weil
man so ein zwischen den beiden Frauen
dann da ist ein Vertrauensverhältnis da
öffnet man sich leichter und wenn ich
jetzt mich diskriminiert fühle als
farbige Person ist ja die Frage ob ich
mich davon da weißen Person richtig
beraten fühle also da ist so eine finde
ich so eine psychologisch emotionale
Ebene die ist nicht nicht ganz greifbar
zum Thema
Punkt
wer eine Uni von innen gesehen hat weiß
das dass der AStA in der Regel links ist
oder die Student in den Sternchen
Sternchen Sternchen schafft natürlich
auch ganz klar das ist an der
Humboldt-Uni auch der Fall ich glaube
der Punkt ob man das nachvollziehen kann
oder nicht ich weiß nicht ob der so
richtig zutrifft es gibt ja auch den
Fall aus Hannover beispielsweise von dem
Afrika Historiker Professor Blei 60
Jahre geforscht und da wurde jetzt da
gab es sollte es im März in Hannover von
der Stadt Hannover
eine Diskussionsrunde geben ein Panel
vierfaches Panel online natürlich weil
die Pandemie noch war und dann gab es
eine sogenannte
antidiskriminierungsgruppe und die hat
dafür gesorgt dass am Ende dieser
Professor Blei mit seinen 60 Jahren
Forschungsergebnissen die ja eigentlich
hat natürlich ein weißer alter Mann aber
über Afrika dass der ausgeladen wurde
wie kann er halt sein also die Stadt
Hannover lädt ihn ein da gibt es eine
kleine Gruppe die sagt nee nee du bist
ja weiß du darfst über schwarze nicht
reden und deswegen ist egal was du
bisher geforscht hast spielt alles keine
Rolle du hast die falsche Hautfarbe ich
glaube auch das ist Rassismus
die Definition von Rassismus ist
eigentlich die Kategorisierung
Homogenisierung und Abwertung von
Menschen aufgrund von ihrer Hautfarbe
und nicht anders ist das was hier
geschrieben wird wenn man schreibt eine
Empathie voller jemanden kann jemand der
in der Lage die Gefühle von anderen
wahrzunehmen Platz zu geben dann bin ich
einverstanden aber das nur auf der
Hautfarbe zu reduzieren ist nichts
anders als ein reiner klassischer
Rassismus ja man kann sich vorstellen
was aus den Studierenden Studenten darf
man ja auch nicht mehr sagen
diesen Studierenden wenn sie mal einen
Beruf haben in zehn Jahren geworden ist
und was die dann veranstalten in ihrem
Einflussbereich in irgendeiner Firma wo
sie aber in einer Behörde in irgendeinem
Büro einer Anwaltskanzlei oder was auch
immer das greift ja um sich greift immer
weiter um sich und das nicht schon immer
es gibt ja inzwischen auch
rassismusdebatten wenn in einer
Fernsehsendung
überwiegend oder nur weißer rumlaufen
also der wird ja darüber das Glück da
müssen unbedingt auch farbiger oder
schwarze mit rein um das zu mischen
selbst wenn das in Bayern spielt musste
ist das einfach notwendig sonst ist es
wahrscheinlich auch zu viele Männer ähm
Leute
ganz toll ja genau genetisch gesehen 99%
aus Nahen Osten das heißt 99%, also
Runde ist okay eigentlich nicht weiß
wie die Gesellschaft wir sind Diversion
sehr gut also wir sind heute sehr sehr
gut aber ich weiß ja nicht wie es Dir
geht Frank habe ich habe ich wurde auch
schon mal also ich wurde auch schon
öfter gebeten zu kommen weil ja noch
eine Frau dabei sein müsste ist es dir
auch schon mal passiert die Quotenfrau
zu sein muss ich nachdenken also die
Quoten Frau so wie du es jetzt
beschreibst war ich in der Tat noch
nicht aber ich stimme zu dieses diesen
ich sag mal diese diese Empfindlichkeit
die Teile ich auch nicht ich gendere
nicht aber nicht weil ich es respektlos
bin sondern weil ich denke man kann auch
sagen die Lehrerinnen und der Lehrer ich
finde diese diese verständ Versicherung
und der Hicks das brauchst für mich
nicht und ich bin und da bekenne ich
mich auch zu ein absolut alter Männer
Fan weil ich habe einfach ein Podcast
mit Heiner Bremer und der ist mein
politischer Mentor und ich schätze seine
Erfahrung und ich möchte diese Menschen
gar nicht wissen wer hat mich zum Stern
geholt das ist natürlich viele
Jahrzehnte her und von daher kann man
echt nur so sagen
mich eher Menschen
die ich viele und ich finde die haben
auch mit seinem Umfeld wenn man gutes
Verhältnis zu sein großer seinen Eltern
hat also für mich gibt es diese Debatte
nicht und ich muss auch sagen ich
versuche sie im Alltag auch zu umgehen
mich da nicht reinzuschauen muss ist
glaube ich dass man solchen Debatten
hier entgegentritt sobald man das
feststellt man darf nicht an sich
vorbeiziehen lassen man muss langsam was
macht ihr hier überhaupt noch mal drüber
nachgedacht ansonst das das
Ufer derartige Haus und du erkennst am
Ende die Gesellschaft nicht mehr das
soll nicht klingen dass man den Kampf
gegen Rassismus irgendwie lächerlich
machen will darum geht es nicht das ist
enorm wichtig auch um die Frauen mehr
Möglichkeiten und Gleichberechtigung
anzubieten ist wichtig aber ich bin ja
arabisch sozialisiert die arabische
Sprache ist genderzeit mehr als zwei
tausend Jahren und trotzdem geht die
Frauen in diese Gesellschaft nicht gut
also man muss realistische Maßnahmen
finden die die Gleichberechtigung und
Antidiskriminierung Bekämpfung besser
und produktiv gekämpft und nicht auf
symbol-
den wir hier erleben dass es Rassismus
aus Gründen des Antirassismus